good afternoon I'm most I'm brunner
president of the Center for national
policy and i'd like to welcome all of
you to this newsmaker luncheon this is a
anniversary we have now had the
opportunity to host the chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisers and other
members of the CEA in announcing and
discussing the economic report of the
president for several years in a row
this I think is our second opportunity
to host Joe Stiglitz who will be our
speaker today Joe is the chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisers and i think
i'd like to just say one word about the
council i think most people in
Washington know this but it's good to be
reminded that the council was formed I
think in the 40s 4046 1946 that's right
it was it was meant to do two things I
think one was to bring together some
prominent economists from the academic
world to give professional advice to the
president and the other was to be a
voice in a center for objective
information about the economy to the
country as a whole to the rest of us I
think over the years these functions
have been performed sometimes adequately
sometimes very well in my view the
current council both under the
chairmanship of dr. Stiglitz and its
predecessor Laura Tyson has done a
really good job of focusing on these two
missions and really sticking with them
Joe is a member of the council has been
a member since july of 1993 he was
appointed chairman by president clinton
in june of 1995 a very well-known
academic economist responsible for a new
field the economics of information and
important to the dialogue here in
Washington I think ideas about the role
that government has to play in fixing up
what the market doesn't do very well the
record
the Clinton administration in this
council I think speaks for itself US
economy is in great shape overall I
think we're going to hear a lot more
about that today although we still have
some things to work on like average
wages not all of us agree on exactly the
nature of that problem but I think it's
still out there and I guess I would
respectfully disagree a little bit with
President Clinton I don't think that the
argument about the involvement of
government in our lives is quite over
yet so people like Joe Stiglitz his
colleague Alicia man L from the bank
from the CEA is also here are working on
that argument this is this is the report
and he's going to show it to you in a
minute I'm going to give you a little
peek because I just want to be able to
say that it's the color of money today
dr. Stiglitz is leaving the council and
will become the chief economist and
senior vice president for development at
the World Bank I think tomorrow if i'm
not mistaken so we're very glad to
welcome him here on his way from the
overall US economic interests to the
world perspective on overall US economic
interests dr. Stiglitz
actually the green is for the
environment it isn't for money is a very
important point thank you it's a
pleasure to be here I want to thank the
Center for national policy for again
hosting the release of the annual
economic report of the president in
particular I want to thank most
Steinbrenner and ancillary for all their
help in arranging this event I also want
to thank my colleagues Jeff Frankel and
Alicia Monell for all their hard work
and dedication in producing this year's
report next I want to thank the staff
many of whom are here with us today as
usual you have gone above and beyond and
producing a document that is more than
just a very important historical record
you hope that this year's economic
report of the president will help to
frame key aspects of the upcoming policy
debate you should be very proud of your
contributions as you know the economic
report of the president is submitted to
Congress every year and fulfillment of
the requirement imposed by the
Employment Act of nineteen forty six
this landmark legislation enunciated for
the first time government's
responsibility for management of the
economy it assigned to the federal
government the responsibility to promote
maximum employment production and
purchasing power in this the 51st first
year since that act I am pleased to
report the state of the nation's economy
is excellent in many respects the
economy is as strong as it has been in
three decades unemployment is low
inflation is moderate and stable
investment and exports are high and
there's evidence that the fruits of this
prosperity are alas being shared more
equitably by all Americans I could go on
a great greater length about the
economic achievements of the last four
years the policies that contributed to
them but I think the more important
contribution made by the economic report
of the president is to produce and
disseminate the ideas and analysis that
are an important input to the process of
designing better policies for the
future my time today I would like to
outline for the major challenges that we
still face and suggest that some of the
policies that will compute some of the
policies that will contribute to solving
them I will begin my remarks today by
discussing an economic philosophy that
delimits the role of government in a new
era this philosophy has guided the
Clinton administration's policies for
the past four years providing the basis
of many of the important achievements I
alluded to a few moments ago there is
still much work to be done however and
in the second part of my remarks I will
identify and discuss some of the major
challenges that we still face when needs
an economic philosophy to define the
role of government in the new era and to
impose discipline and consistency in a
time of financial stretching see the
formulation and implementation of an
innovative economic philosophy will
perhaps come to be viewed as the Clinton
administration's most enduring
contribution in the past two opposing
visions of the American economy had vie
for dominance to put it starkly one is a
pen glossy and view of an America of
vigorous self-sufficient individualism
the other of a world in which government
is primarily responsible for our
well-being over the past four years this
administration has promoted a third
vision one that synthesizes in
transcends these two polar views it
finds the middle ground between the New
Deal view of government now more than 60
years old and Reaganomics which left our
economy in shambles this vision puts
individuals at extender but emphasizes
that individuals live with within and
draw strength from communities it
recognizes that many have been left
behind by the changing economy and may
need government assistance but that the
role for government is limited it can
and should promote opportunity not
dependents this new vision includes a
renewed conception of government one in
which government recognizes both the
markets efficiencies and its limitations
the government can sometimes make
markets work better but dis sodam in a
position to replace them
government to Haziq strengths and its
limitations we need to understand those
limitations and we're possible work to
improve government's performance the
government cannot ignore the role of
market forces in its own programs it
needs to take advantage of the power of
incentives to accomplish its objectives
the question is seldom whether the
government should replace the market but
rather whether government can usefully
complement the market over the years
economists have identified the various
circumstances in which markets fail to
produce desirable outcomes and we select
the government invention can complement
the market competition may be imperfect
market participants may lack needed
information and markets may be missing
would be innovators and entrepreneurs
may fail to capture enough of the
benefits of their activity to justify
their efforts or the users of resources
such as clean air and water may scape
the full cost of their use degrading the
resources for all as a result by itself
markets may produce too little of some
goods like basic research and too much
of others like pollution or toxic wastes
although such problems may occur
throughout the economy it is important
for the government to focus on those
that are particularly severe like any
successful enterprise it must identify a
core mission and pursue it the criteria
for government involvement in any
activity should not be how essential
that activity is to the economy or how
many jobs that can generate or how much
it contributes to the trade balance in
the overwhelming number of cases the
government cannot hope to surpass
private firms a generating output jobs
or exports the proper question in
circumstances where a choice between
government and the market arises is
whether there is any reason not to rely
on markets is there in the language of
economists a market failure these
principles provide a general guide for
thinking about the role of government in
addressing the many challenges we still
face and the next part of my talk I
would describe four of these challenges
the economic challenges of an aging
population the increase in inequality
and persistence of poverty the problem
of displaced workers and the
international challenges I want to
emphasize at the onset that this list of
challenges is not meant to be
comprehensive and this year's economic
report needs to be read in conjunction
with the last three years reports for
instance among the most important
challenges facing the country is the
slowdown in productivity which began in
the early 1970s the sources of economic
growth the explanations of the slowdown
and the design of policies to address
the slowdown where subjects explored in
last year's report their absence here
should not be interpreted as reflecting
any D munition the importance of this
key issue Rover last year's economic
report set the stage for several of the
discussions we explore in greater detail
this year such as the economic
challenges of an aging population an
issue to which I now turn in the last
four years we have taken tremendous
steps towards balancing the budget the
deficit has fallen by sixty-three
percent from 290 billion in fiscal year
nineteen ninety two to one hundred and
seven billion in fiscal year nineteen
ninety six as important as deficit
reduction has been there is general
recognition that it will only have been
a temporary palliative if we do not sell
the long-run challenges associated with
the aging population chart one that I
hope has been distributed shows the
projective federal expenditures under
current policy for Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid all are expected
to grow substantially over the coming
decades as the population ages
expenditures on Social Security are
expected to grow from four point six
percent of GDP in 1996 to roughly six
and a half percent in the year 2030 and
then to stabilize a much more serious
challenge is posed by Medicaid and
Medicare if nothing is done to reform
these programs their outlays are
projected to grow from three point five
percent of GDP in 1996 to roughly
thirteen percent
in the year 2050 their projected growth
is do not just to the aging of the
population as in the case of social
security but also to the expectation
that the volume and intensity of medical
services consumed will continue their
rapid rise chapter 3 of the economic
report of the president describes the
dimensions of the problem and also
analyzes the consequences proposed
alternative solutions there is no
consensus on long-term solutions to
these challenges witness the divided
recommendations of the recent
quadrennial Advisory Council on Social
Security but I think that this chapter
by improving our understanding of the
problem makes a large stride forward in
advancing us towards a solution in fact
it is the first time that this crucial
issue has ever been treated
systematically in the economic report of
the president in looking for a solution
to the financial problems facing these
programs we need to be mindful of the
contributions that these programs have
made in increasing economic security
among the aged and reducing poverty to
the point that today poverty among the
elderly has reached the lowest level
since the data began to be collected
more than four decades ago of the
financing problems to be solved that a
Social Security is the most tractable
nevertheless it will be a challenge to
restore a long-term balance to the
program raise national savings and allow
Social Security to continue to fulfill
its many missions the president said in
the State of the Union we must agree to
a bipartisan process to preserve Social
Security proposals that have been made
for Social Security contain different
elements we need to keep in mind that
programs that look quite different
consumer can have similar effects the
national savings a source of concern to
almost all economists are on the rate of
return to social security contributions
but different impacts and transaction
costs and risks distribution in contrast
to Social Security Medicare faces
short-term as well as long-term
financing challenges also the long-run
problems facing Medicare are not as well
understood as those facing social
security in the possible solutions
are more tentative the sections of sex
chapter 3 of the report on Medicare in
long-term with care within the Medicaid
program pay considerable attention to
two sets of economic issues incentive
effects and adverse selection instead of
effects are particularly important
because these programs involve a number
of players health care providers and
private insurance companies in addition
to taxpayers and current beneficiaries
adverse selection sometimes referred to
as cream skimming or cherry-picking
refers to the incentives under many
reimbursement schemes for providers or
insurers to attempt to get to get
low-risk patients in some cases cases
profits can be creased more by
attracting low-risk patients than by
improving services some proposed reforms
may exacerbate the potential for adverse
selection thus deflecting incentives in
the wrong direction while other reforms
are intended either reduced fix cope or
deal with this consequences as we
evaluate these alternatives we will need
to look closely not only at who is
affected but at the key economic impacts
impacts on incentives on adverse
selection and on competition I want to
turn now from the challenge of the aging
population a problem with which we shall
have to deal over many decades to a
problem which is pressing today the rise
of inequality chapter 5 of the economic
report focuses on this issue over 30
years ago president john f kennedy
commented that a rising tide lifts all
boats indeed the events of the decade
preceding his presidency and the decade
following it supported this statement
tremendous economic growth brought
increasing incomes for all families
including the poor income inequality
fell dramatically evidence since the
late 1970s however suggests that not all
boats are necessarily lifted by a rising
tide chart to shows how dramatically the
situation changed during the 1980s and
early 1990s more than half of the
household saw the real incomes fall if
the CPI were biased upward there would
not be as many losers in absolute terms
but the relative picture that the richer
the group the greater the gangs would be
unchanged another metric for measuring
the increasing inequality is the Gini
coefficient which has been rising
steadily since nineteen sixty eight what
has caused this increased dispersion in
household incomes at least half of the
increased inequality comes from
increased increasing Labor earnings
inequality for men much of the trend in
earnings inequality is the result of
rising premiums earned by some classes
of workers especially the well-educated
and high skilled the returns to
education grew tremendously during the
1980s and early 1990s as shown in chart
three in 1980 a male college graduate
earned one-third more than his
counterpart with only a high school
education in 1993 the college premium
had grown to more than seventy percent
there are a number of explanations for
this dramatic increase in the returns to
college we can rule out changes in
supply of workers with large increases
in the college educated workforce supply
effects should have decreased the
premium instead the most promising
explanation sent around increases the
demand for skilled workers as new
technologies have been integrated into
the production process firms have
increased their demand for workers
capable of using this new technology
evidence indicates for instance their
workers who use a computer on their job
earn significantly more than those who
do not skill bias technological change
can certainly account for the rise in
earnings inequality between different
groups interestingly chapter 5 shows
that even more of the overall increase
in earnings inequality is a result of
more dispersion within groups that share
the same education experience and
demographic traits although a number of
creative theories can explain increased
differentials among seemingly similar
workers there is little empirical
evidence on this a very important puzzle
from the early 1970s through 1992 the
trend of increasing income inequality
was clear and pervasive income
statistics from nineteen ninety three to
nineteen ninety-five the most recent
year for which data are available
provide
evidence that this trend may have been
reversed the poverty rate fell from 15.1
percent in 1993 to 13.8 percent in 1995
marking the largest two-year reduction
in poverty since 1973 and this is based
on the official poverty rate which is
before taxes if we include the effects
of the Earned Income Tax Credit the eitc
reduction in the poverty rate has been
it even more dramatic incomes at all
points of the distribution have
increased since 1993 and the gangs have
been largest for low-income households
as shown in chart for this is the first
time this has happened again since 1973
the reduction inequality can also be
seen in the Gini coefficient which
declined by more than more last year
than in any year since nineteen sixty
eight again without even taking the EITC
into account these reversals while
dramatic do not come close to undoing
the 20 years of increasing inequality
also it seems rash declared definitely
and into a 20-year trend based on two
years of data this is especially the
case for a complex phenomena like
inequality whose causes we do not fully
understand still some explanation for
the reversal suggests that we are seeing
the beginning of a new trend part of the
progress is due to good macroeconomic
conditions in particular to following
unemployment the report however suggests
that poverty and inequality have fallen
by fallen by much more than would be
predicted from aggregate variables alone
more tellingly the college wage premium
has begun to fall which you can see by
looking back at chart 3 this is
translated into a narrowing of the
earnings gap between the median worker
and the workers at the bottom end of the
income distribution if this is the
consequence of the increased supply of
college graduates we can expect to see
further reductions in this premium in
the future the reduced education premium
may in turn have an impact on the
long-term trend towards increased
enrollment in higher education both
short-run and long-run policies are
needed to help reduce
come in equality further in the short
run the Earned Income Tax Credit the
eitc can help raise the incomes of
workers with low earnings in 1995 almost
3.3 million people were lifted out of
poverty by the eitc the recent increase
the minimum wage will further enhance
the poverty reducing power of the eitc
ultimately however transfer payments can
only mitigate the consequences of the
market to make lasting changes in
inequality we need to address the
distribution of earnings among workers
this can be accomplished by providing
greater access to education and to
training programs that help create a
more uniformly high skilled workforce
let me now turn to a third issue an
issue which has been at the center of
public policy discussion during much of
the past year well everyone throughout
the world recognized marveled at the
success of the American economy and
creating jobs the American job machine
some worried about the quality of these
jobs there were glib remarks about
hamburger tossers at a conference of the
economic leaders in the industrialized
countries the job someone held in lille
france last april when european official
was prayer phrased as quipping you
Americans have created many jobs but
they have not been good jobs we have not
created any we have not created any jobs
but had we created them they would have
been good jobs they were surprised when
we reported that more than two-thirds of
the new jobs that would have been
created in the American economy were in
our industry occupation categories
paying more than the median wage in
another disparaging remark about the US
labor market a worker was quoted as
saying yes i know we have created at the
time 8 million new jobs i have three of
them but again a close look at the
statistics belies this image the
fraction of workers that are part-time
because they could not get full-time
work has actually fallen chapter 4 the
economic report of the president
explores these and other changes in
america's labor market in addition to
the facts cited above we showed that the
rate of job loss has fallen one measure
permanent job losers unemployed less
than five weeks is shown in shard five
and shows this dramatically nevertheless
a few areas of weakness persist chart
ship's chart six shows that according to
a range of measures wages have been
relatively flat for the past 15 years
although this may be partially an
artifact of upward bias and the CPI well
the evidence we present drawing on
several alternative data sources does
not suggest a marked worsening the
problem of dislocated workers the fact
is that this location does continue to
pose costs for those who lose their jobs
we can and should undertake policies
that reduce those costs the most
important policy is of course to
maintain a strong macro economy which
ensures that there are jobs available
for those who are displaced improvements
in the unemployment insurance system
increased portability of pension and
health benefits and proposed reforms to
our reemployment and training services
can all help ease the transition between
jobs data show that more educated
workers face lower costs and making
transitions and thus improved access to
education will provide lasting benefits
over the long term let me now turn to
the fourth challenge that posed by the
international arena international
economic policy has come to play a
central role in this country's overall
economic strategy some of this
administration's greatest and most
lasting achievements have been in this
arena with establishment of the north
american free trade area nafta and the
completion of the ERG way round of gap
negotiations and establishment of the
World Trade Organization and through the
asia-pacific economic cooperation APEC
forum in the free-trade area of
America's we have set the agenda in our
relations with the Pacific Rim countries
in the countries of Latin America for
years to come these and other agreements
have set the stage for a vast expansion
of trade X parks are up more than a
third since the beginning of 1993 this
increase has not only fueled America's
economic expansion accounting for
one-third of growth in the last
for years it has also contributed
importantly to our rising standard of
living job supported by goods exports
pay about thirteen to sixteen percent
more than the average job in the United
States Chapter seven attempts to put
into perspective the changes in the
world scene to provide a framework for
thinking about international economic
policy in the coming decades there have
been three major changes in the global
economy over the past several years the
end of the Cold War has got to an
increased emphasis and economics and
international relations over long Orizon
the increasing importance of the East
and Southeast Asian economies has been
shifting the center of gravity of the
world economy west towards the Pacific
and over and even longer horizon we
continue to witness the globalization of
the world economy a shrinking of
economic and intellectual distances to
reduce transport costs and improved
telecommunications as always changes in
the world of ideas parallel those in the
real world for example the rise of Asia
with growth rates that dwarf those
enjoyed recently by the West has
demonstrated the development is indeed
possible and has stimulated a heated
debate within the economics community
about the optimal policies for spurring
development their transition to the
post-cold war world has not been a
smooth one and many of the old ways of
thinking persist with military metaphors
extending to the world of trade with a
trade deficit replacing the missile gap
as the object of concern economic
competition differs fundamentally from
the kind of competition that
characterized the Cold War first
economic competition rest on an
underlying cooperative structure of fair
rules as embodied in the World Trade
Organization and the gap before it
second and perhaps more importantly
international economic relations are
clearly positive some trade promotes the
living standards of all participants by
allowing us to focus on those areas in
which we are relatively productive for
example during the 19th century a
substantial part of us productivity
growth was caused by the shift from
agriculture to industry today exports
are our new frontier
shifting resources into export
production will be one of the most
effective ways of increasing
productivity over the long run recent
trade developments as discussed earlier
have been excellent in order to
consolidate and extend these gangs
however it is more important than ever
for us to have a guiding principle to
justify and reevaluate our international
economic role role chapter seven of the
economic report suggests that we think
of a central goal of international
relations as the provision of
international public goods and the
mitigation of externalities concepts
that we have that have long been central
in thinking about the role of government
at the domestic level has long been
recognized that the market if left alone
will tend to under produce these Goods
just as government's need to provide
national defense protect the environment
and finance basic scientific research so
international arrangements are needed
for the provision of international
public goods chapter 7 discusses four
important categories of such goods
International Economic Cooperation peace
and order the environment and basic
research these are all areas in which
international cooperation can provide
benefits to the United States while also
benefiting other countries economic
cooperation may be the most fundamental
international public good of all
development and security are one example
spill overs from Economic Cooperation
all nations benefit as developing
countries grow in addition economic
development restraint may restrain
political pressures within countries
increasing international security in
conclusion let me note the several
unifying themes that run throughout this
year's economic report of the president
one is that most of the challenges we
face have deep roots in the past just as
the increase in inequality to name one
example has no single simple cause
neither do any of the challenges we face
of any single simple solution it is a
fan of fantasy to believe that any magic
policy wand can transport us back to the
income distribution or productivity
growth that American enjoyed in the
1960s it takes time to respond
effectively to
even more time to reverse trains that
have been two decades in the making to
take just one example among myriad the
purely economic benefits of hex tire
take 15 years or more to ripen the time
it takes for a hexed our child to grow
up and join the labor force the second
unifying theme is a message of hope
problems that seem intractable like
ballooning budget deficits can be
addressed but they are most effectively
addressed in ways that rise above
partisan partisanship too often I've
seen partisan battles who closed off
opportunities for major reforms that
would potentially benefit almost
everyone while hurting almost no one the
third unifying theme concerns the role
of government in dealing with these
long-term problems I believe that our
efforts to redefine the role of
government will be one of the lasting
achievements of this administration
something often called the New
Democratic vision our new vision focuses
focuses on opportunity and
responsibility at both the national
international and individual level the
government must assume the
responsibility of changing itself to
meet the enormous changes in our economy
that have already occurred and that will
continue to develop one of the first
steps is to demonstrate that we can be
fiscally responsible these fiscal
constraints mean that the government
cannot do everything instead of viewing
this as a problem I view it is it up as
an opportunity to redefine our mission
to focus on those tasks which are which
are uniquely the government's
responsibility and the most general
responsibility is to ensure that all
Americans have the opportunity to live
up to their potential individuals must
assume however the responsibility for
grabbing those opportunities many of the
long-term trends I discussed are
worrying instead of ignoring or
lamenting these challenges the nation
must embrace them transform transforming
these problems into opportunities we can
do this only if we set a coherent
economic agenda this administration has
already accomplished much with the
policies the last four years
over the next four years the
administration will continue to build on
those policies holding fast to its
vision of the government's role in
economy as the basis for an agenda to
promote growth opportunity and
responsibility thank you we answer some
questions thanks very much dr. Stiglitz
has to go testify before the Joint
Economic Committee but we have time I
think for a couple of questions um
here's one over here by the World Bank
the the international agenda that you
outline seems quite controversial in
Congress from many ends of the political
spectrum and I'm wondering how difficult
will your new job be in the absence of
support in Congress for the overseas
Private Investment Corporation and other
US government institutions dedicated to
promoting foreign investment by US
companies in emerging markets well the
issue of foreign investment is actually
one of the topics that we do discuss XM
lanes in chapter 7 there has been a
tremendous amount of foreign investment
one of the points that we emphasized in
the chapter is the important link
between this foreign investment on an US
export US trade this link means that
American companies investing abroad then
are in a position to to sing American
goods goods produced in America and sell
them abroad from our perspective then
that not only is it this goes back to
the theme that I talked about in my
remarks today international trade
international investment are win-win
situations we are better off as a result
of this the foreign country is better
off we are better off because we we
export more we are better off because we
get higher returns than we otherwise
would have gotten so as an economy we
are better off but for income foreign
countries are better off because of the
obvious growth that it that it brings to
them so
I view this as very much win-win
situations one of our job will be to try
to communicate that view and to say you
know this is not a Cold War issue this
is really a post Cold War II issue where
we have to look at how we can work
together to make us all better off
essentially argues that a little bit of
inflation is not necessarily a bad thing
in that actually trying to achieve zero
inflation would have harmful effects and
that contrary to the notion of the Fed
should get out ahead of the curve and
preempt inflation that they we should be
cautiously expansionary and wait until
we see inflation but what what does this
argument pretend for what does this
imply for where monetary policy should
be heading this year well a general
tenant of the administration not to
comment on Fed policy and and let me the
purpose of the report is to set the
stage for discussions which are going on
all the time about what are the stance
abroad or macroeconomic policy I think I
think macroeconomic policy is an issue
that is a concern to all Americans and
and ought to be a subject of public
policy to debate one just for those who
have had a chance to read the whole
report yet what we try to do in that
chapter is discuss a number of key
issues that have been on the public
policy debate one of them is what has
happened to narrow and how it the
evidence oh the the what has happened to
the level of unemployment below which
inflation starts to rise it used to be
thought that if unemployment got below
six percent or six point two percent
inflation ought to begin to rise we've
now had two more than two years in which
in unemployment is below six percent no
signs of rising inflation in fact the
core rate of inflation which is the rate
of inflation excluding the volatile
energy and
food prices has actually fallen during
the last year by about point three
percent now another aspect of of the
discussion the macroeconomic section is
that as our economy has changed as we've
moved into this low and stable
inflationary environment we need to
re-examine a whole set of issues
pertaining to macroeconomic policy one
thing that we we point out is that the
evidence the the data which is very
compelling that there are very high
costs of high inflation rates inflation
rates when they get about fifteen
percent do have very serious problems
for economic growth but in the kind of
world that we live in today we're in the
United States inflation has been low and
getting lower it has been very hard for
people to detect any significant
economic costs associated with this
inflation and then we cite one study
that shows that in fact if you try to
get inflation 20 you start running into
problems of adjustment down at the very
very bottom end the other point that we
we point out is that the evidence used
to be there used to be a lot of concern
that the price of dis inflation used to
be very high which meant that if you
overshot if you brought your
unemployment rate down to low and you
got a little bit of a bout of inflation
that inflation would start soaring there
would be people thought of it as a
precipice that you're on a precipice and
if you fell off that precipice things
got worse and worse and that it would be
very costly to undo the evidence
suggests that both of those propositions
there's very little support for them we
do knocks it on a precipice and the cost
of dis inflation are are relatively low
they're basically balanced with the cost
the benefits that you get when you when
you exceed the the target the narrow as
your target so that the risk picture the
risk analysis today with our low
inflationary environment low and stable
was considerably different than it did
save 15 years ago in a quite different
macro
nomics situation and as we go into this
new new situation we need to read the
debates many of these issues over again
you didn't discuss what some of us view
is a important underpinning of our
economy and that is our infrastructure
our ability to get raw materials to
manufacturing and get our goods and
services into the international market
without putting an additional burden on
the pricing structure from this country
can you make some comments about
infrastructure particularly how it's
going to be impacted by the tightening
budget situation that we're going to
face over the next five years there are
many aspects of America's infrastructure
and I think one has to keep in mind the
various aspects one of the aspects
that's very important in you know
America's infrastructure is our
telecommunication system and we do spend
quite a bit of time in the economic
report talking about our
telecommunication system and in
particular the reforms this was awesome
last year's economic report of the
president the reforms that were under in
the bill that was passed last year just
about this time I have and how these are
unfolding today our belief is very
strongly that by getting the right
regulatory structure that promotes
competition we can have a more vital
telecommunications infrastructure which
is really critical in in America's
dominance in international economic
policy the other part of the
infrastructure obviously are our robes
and highways and uh and water actually
there are there other pranks there's
always it and we took we will should i
say other that we have a very brief
discussion in the economic report of the
president in a section where we talk
about fiscal capital and the role of
physical capital I'm like so so
important it's not only the private
sector capital accumulation X important
but the infrastructure which is often
important complement the my remarked I
talked about how the government and the
private sector were complement error
complimentary this is one example good
structure can increase the effectiveness
and returns to private to private
capital there's a third aspect of our
infrastructure that I think is very
important which is our knowledge
infrastructure rrd our basic research
our university system which i think is
an essential part of our infrastructure
that really needs to can have continued
support in years at us ahead the free
trade area of the Americas is one of the
achievements how do you see this
developing and what do you think are the
biggest challenges to get to an
agreement in this in with these
countries well at the summit of the
Americas that occurred in Miami there
was an agreement among the countries of
Latin America other North America and
South American continents to form a
free-trade area over the coming decades
so there is a commitment the issue as
you as you ask is how do we go from
there from where we are here today to to
this free trade area nice i think it's
going to be a a challenge I think it is
is a something in which we will all gain
and I think it's particularly important
that North and South America not break
up into a set of competing smaller
regional groups but try to bring them
all together within a single free trade
area to do this we are going to need
fast track Authority and the president
has emphasized that a number of
occasions the importance of fast track
Authority I think everybody recognizes
that trade negotiations cannot really
proceed without fast-track Authority and
so I I do hope that we will be
successful in getting this fast track
Authority is is the major vehicle for
facilitating this progress
I would certainly agree that the that
exports are the new frontier and and I
and I laud the administration for its
objectives in that direction in that
context I wonder if you would care to
comment on the administration's budget
proposal which proposes to eliminate the
export source rule which the Treasury
Department found in 1993 to be a
stimulant in a good thing for exports
well I don't want to get into detail
coming on specific tax provisions in any
an assessment of any tax provision this
goes back to where you mark that I made
earlier my talk basically as we said the
private sector he has to be the source
of generating exports and jobs dealing
with the other major problems the real
question is the role government needs to
be focused on where it can be most
effective as a complement to the private
sector and it has to be careful that in
doing that it doesn't distort the
allocation of resources the real
question is it needs to create a level
playing field in order that that the
nation's resources be allocated to the
most efficient way not distorted one way
or the other the critical issue here is
yes it may promote exports but does it
do it at the expense of something else
and a full-employment economy it's
important for us to to change our frame
of mind as we've gone into a
full-employment economy it's important
to realize that when you push resources
in one way you're taking them away from
somewhere else if you have a level
playing field you you can be sure that
they're going to the area where the
returns are highest except in those well
define cases where there's a reason the
market is not getting the right signals
for instance example is we under invest
in in in basic research because people
aren't able to get the full returns we
under invest in and reducing pollution
because the polluters don't pay for the
full cost of their of their pollution so
there are some well-defined areas where
we we have to selectively intervene
because the market
not getting there the price system
doesn't convey the right information the
real question that one needs to ask in
the context of any of these tax
provisions is is there a compelling case
that the market by itself is having
insufficient incentives for promoting
exports and I think the judgment was
that in this particular case there was
not a compelling case I'm going to just
take privilege of asking a question up
here if picking up on what you were just
saying about a full-employment economy
as you look at the year ahead what can
we say about what's likely to happen to
average wages and if it's a positive
story can it be can it be a story that's
told without the fed feeling that it has
to trump on the brakes without Tony okay
well as as we said that the long-term
trend on on real wages has not has been
one has been the picture that we gave
you which is that that they have risen
but only at a very moderate rate or
perhaps even fallen the exact rate of
increased depends on how you adjust for
inflation if there is a bias in the CPI
of that it really changes the picture of
whether it's a slight decrease or a
slight increase but it's obviously you
can say it's not good enough now in the
last last year or two there are the
evidence is that real wages have been
increasing and if we use a corrected CPI
increasing even even more there are a
couple factors as we look forward that
may account for this rise if you look at
the relationship between real wages and
productivity real wages where you adjust
not by the CPI but by the GDP deflator
have been tracking productivity but
there's been a wedge over the last few
years between the CPI and the GDP
deflator this sounds very technical but
in fact that in other words the price
index that affects goods in general for
all goods and the price index that
effects consumption goods the good the
goods that workers consume have have
diverged a little bit we are forecasting
that this divergence will be reduced
markedly in the coming years and if that
happens and productivity stays at the
same rate real wages as defined by CPI
will start rising at a more rapid rate
moreover there are some evidence that
productivity may actually be rising
slightly the evidence is that as you
know one of the problems is that that
we've one of the issues that we
discussed an economic report of the
present in chapter 2 is that there are
significant measurement problems one
aspect of the measurement problem is
that there are two ways of measuring the
size of the economy one way focuses on
income the other way focuses on output
in all your economics courses you were
always taught that those two numbers are
supposedly the same but in fact when
these statisticians measure them they
come out different and they come out
very very different over the last
several quarters the difference has been
at the rate of one percent per year
actually the last the third quarter of
1996 the difference was two percent the
very big difference we think and reasons
given and the economic part of the
president that income provides the
better measure and that's the measure
that has traditionally been used for
measuring productivity if you look at
that measure productivity productivity
the rate of increase of productivity has
increased from it's one point one
percent trend that's prevailed since
1973 to about 1.4 1.5 percent so there's
an increase in productivity so if you
combine the increase in productivity
with a decrease in the wedge between the
GDP deflator and the CPI you get a
prospect for an increase in real wages
that is really quite significant over
the coming years so on that note we'll
be back here next year at this time
looking for good news thanks very much
doctor soon